[Music]
yeah it's big obviously last year we
were so bad in division and this year to
be 3-0 for the first time
uh since 2012 tom thank you
uh is pretty uh pretty fun we know
what's in front of us we got
a stretch now of uh
we had seven games
out of division and finished with three
in a division so we got to put ourselves
in a position
um
you know to make a run
and uh we've done
our part so far in the division
aaron rodgers after last night's victory
they have had a favorable schedule from
the standpoint of home games five out of
six games will have been played at
lambeau field wouldn't you like to have
some of those games in december chris
five of their f i mean look at that
after the week one at chicago they've
had five of six games at home they have
one more at home against the raiders
then they go to play the chiefs in
kansas city sunday night football week
eight then at the chargers which will
probably be a packers home game if
sunday night's game against the steelers
is any indication but uh at the 49ers
you know the scout you're looking at the
schedule the rest of the schedule
there's a lot of wins lurking there even
though they're gonna be away from home
the packers off to a great start at five
and one
uh you know they're getting closer and
closer to a team that we can
pencil in maybe even use ink for the
playoffs the question is what seed are
they gonna have yeah no i i think the
you know not every win has been real
impressive but i think the thing we look
at is i just go man they find a way to
win week by week and it's not like
they've had a cupcake schedule at this
point you know you look at the teams
they beat the bears the vikings the
broncos the cowboys the lions not a bad
group you know they were on the one yard
line there to beat the eagles at home
too
but you're right going on the road late
in the year
that will be a little bit of a challenge
you know yes certainly go home field
advantage in december
in late november in green bay is a real
thing because teams got to go up there
and deal with the elements and the cold
and land ball field and all of that but
uh this team is you know they got it
rolling a little bit the way their
defense rebounded after kind of being on
its heels late last night you know the
run game we're continuing to see wait
right
we criticized the lines for not scoring
touchdowns yeah the packers defense had
something to do with that no doubt right
this is my miss mike pettin man he's
he's a hell of a coach uh he really is i
mean you know again i always go back to
you know what he did in cleveland you
know we look back in you know
hindsight's 2020 it wasn't that bad of a
job for what he was dealing with and
that crap that was going on there at
that time uh he's got he knows how to
adjust on the fly his defenses are
versatile he can do everything and you
know the offense hey the offense is the
question mark you know i mean the lack
of weapons especially with no devante
adams you know i mean i go on radio
shows every week and i i challenge host
so tell me who the other receivers are
on green bay and you know these are not
exactly household names aaron rodgers is
throwing to but you know he's talented
enough and they have enough of a formula
on the offensive side of the ball on the
floor staying patient with the run game
is really giving them an advantage and
they're playing a team game right now
i need to track down some of these radio
spots where you're essentially aaron
rodgers baghdad bob you know it because
i have a feeling that's how it goes hey
here's another thing too
let's not assume that they're going to
roll over your guy john gruden no on
sunday he's got two weeks to get ready
for this one he's coming back to green
bay where his coaching career had had
some of its roots he was you know
bounced around in a few different places
before we became the offensive
coordinator of the eagles but uh
they may have something up their sleeve
for aaron rodgers and company i don't
doubt that at all i mean the raiders the
one thing we've talked about i know
through their little win streak i mean
they play tough they're physical they
can run the ball you know the packers
run defense i still got questions about
that and then like you said gruden's had
two weeks and uh you know he's a crazy
man he'll get in the lab and and
invent some crazy plays to help them
gash green bay a little bit it'll be a
fun game i i do think that we will see
that nonetheless
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports